I got your wallets and graduations thank
you oh yeah there's a lot of fun yeah
like that so I am an avid listener this
neon coast-to-coast
get your newsletter I'm 60 years old I
would say I'm in very good health
except for one pesky little problem I
have Hashimoto's I have been taking
medications for about 10 years for that
okay
onion woody way I weigh about 154 and
I'm fine okay
five six okay well that's pretty good
for a girl okay any other problems skin
problems or history of asthma bronchitis
anything like that no okay good
no I have a pressure all right I just
saw a doctor of pharmacist Ben
newsletter where he talked about
autoimmune diseases and what she should
take for them and I would love to do
that but here's my problem
I get really sick when I take vitamins
I've tried everything I tried taking
with food some doctors have telling me
you've got to cheap of brands you need
to buy more expensive brands so my
problem is and my question is why is
that and what can I do about it survive
got to be on the program okay well you
have to appreciate that a lot of
vitamins supplements actually have
gluten in them okay which is a filler
and they like to think it's helpful
because it has wheat in barley rye and
oak proteins in them and they can be a
negative for people they can cause
diarrhea they can cause constipation
they can cause people to have belly pain
even appendicitis Crohn's disease
colitis diverticulitis leaky guts and
all that kind of stuff all which makes
your belly hurt and so I'd get rid of
all the bad foods fried foods processed
meats oils and glutens and what would
you what would you have Kim take as a
supplement program to start out with
charmaine choice under 54 pounds well I
would never take one or two healthy of
factors you doesn't have any other
issues a husband start packs but two of
them would do this job yeah that's a
good place to start
Healthy Start pack and and Hashimoto's
is a thyroid problem so what would you
add to the Healthy Start pack to make
that a thyroid heavy I would add some
oceans Gold oceans don't see I get two
bottles of the oceans gold per month has
take three twice a day and if you you
know feel queasy or something like that
try cutting everything in half okay and
whatever your calculator doses cut
everything in half and take a half at
breakfast habits their time but chars
right to start out with one or is to I'd
go with two Healthy Start packs per
month to fold those four thing twice a
day you had two bottles of the oceans
gold sinking through those twice a day
three of those tablets a day and then
make sure you're eating eggs you know
soft scrambled soft-boiled that kind of
stuff what would you what would you what
would you also take out of the top
besides we brought around Oh char to
help the thyroid heal itself
Curtis yes but I can't the Bulls you got
it right that's close enough
you get an a-plus here and cruciferous
vegetables Kim include cabbage broccoli
cauliflower Brussels sprouts kale and
here is all those things and because
they do interfere with thyroid function
so you got to get them out out of your
diet and many people say well I love all
that stuff well that's maybe why you're
having problems with your thyroid
because those types of vegetables if you
have one serving a week no problem if
you're having a serving at breakfast
lunch and dinner every day you're going
to have a problem and then of course all
the different variations in between so
these are sort of things you need to be
aware of and that's why we're here to
educate people and make sure that
everybody can in fact be the best they
can be maximize your genetic potential
for health and longevity and for
intelligence speed and strength and
fending off disease